Виписка із протоколу номер 42 засідання трійки НКВС Одеської області
від 21 вересня 1937 року.  Звинувачується у тому,
що систематично на квартирі у Фікса проходили контрреволюційні зібрання,
де в різкому антирадянському дусі обговорювалися заходи партії, влади,
висловлювалися побажання найшвидшої окупації України Німеччиною.
Постановили: Бєліка Георгія Дмитровича розстріляти.
Олександр Атамась зачитує уривок зі справи свого прадіда, болгарина за національністю
і вчителя за фахом Георгія Бєліка. Чоловіка затримали у 1937-му
і відтоді його доля була родині невідома.
Ми майже нічого не знали. Знали, що прадіда забрали вночі і все.
І де він після того, що після того з ним сталося… Думали, що він загинув
під час Другої світової війни, тому що жодної інформації про реабілітацію чи ще про щось нам не надавали.
Щоб з’ясувати, що ж насправді сталося з Георгієм понад 80 років тому,
його правнукові знадобИлося менше місяця. Олександр натрапив на допис
у соцмережі про Консультаційний центр з пошуку інформації про репресованих,
який запрацював рік тому. Там йому порадили, з чого розпочати пошуки та як працювати з архівами.
І вже невдовзі Олександр отримав на електронну пошту майже 120
відсканованих сторінок карної справи свого прадіда.
Я вже не міг працювати. У мене був робочий день, але
поки я не прочитав цю справу, я не міг нічого робити. Я просто вчепився.
Таке відчуття, як коли ти читаєш якусь захопливу книгу і не можеш відірватися,
тобі далі цікаво, що буде далі. Тільки це не книга, це книга моєї родини, скажімо так.
З матеріалів справи Олександр дізнався, що його прадіда Георгія Бєліка
стратили 9 жовтня 1937 року. Підставою для арешту
та смертного вироку стали свідчення лише однієї людини, яка звинуватила
чоловіка у неприхованому незадоволенні радянською владою,
а ще в обговоренні міжнародної політики та злиденного становища селян.
Жодної інформації ані про страту, ані про реабілітацію родина Бєліка
так і не отримала, хоча майже 70 років прожила за однією адресою.
Я думаю, якби в 1956 році це повідомили, то мій дідусь
хоча би більшу половину свого життя жив би зі спокоєм на душі,
що він не син ворога народу, що він не злочинець, що він ні в чому не винен.
Історія Георгія Бєліка, відтворена його правнуком, досить типова для України
радянського періоду. Через репресії у різні роки пройшли всі верстви населення -
від селян до творчої інтелігенції. Особливо масштабні репресії відбулися
у 1937-1938 роках. Їх ініціював особисто Йосиф Сталін.
Підстав, звичайно, не було. Людину влада запідозрювала у нелояльності.
Чи була ця нелояльність справжньою чи вигаданою?
Як правило, дій, які б кваліфікувалися як антисовєтські,
антирадянські виступи, підбурювання до спротиву влади
чи, боронь боже, терор і диверсії, в таких справах не було.
Тому типовим для цих справ, які завершувалися як правило
обвинувальним висновком, був такий підсумок:
"речових доказів у справі не виявлено".
І це було типовим, тобто абсолютна більшість цих справ була сфабрикована.
У часи Радянського Союзу доступ до архівів, де зберігалися ці справи,
був суворо обмеженим. Зі здобуттям незалежності до фондів допустили науковців,
які уклали збірники "Репресовані історією" у кожному регіоні України.
Нині вони налічують приблизно 730 тисяч прізвищ та базову інформацію
про репресованих за політичними мотивами.
Частина цих даних доступна для пошуку онлайн.
З 2015 року повністю відкритим став доступ до архівів і для громадян.
До прикладу, у цих картонних коробках, що зберігаються у Галузевому державному архіві СБУ,
сотні тисяч пожовклих сторінок, на яких прописані долі людей.
Як правило, прикладом документів є кримінальні або архівно-слідчі справи
на тих осіб, які були репресовані. З таких відомих наприклад Василь Стус, Левко Лук’яненко,
Євген Сверстюк і багато інших. Якщо ми говоримо про період репресій,
то це починаючи з 30-х років, "Великий терор"
і також післявоєнний, після Другої світової війни період.
Простіше сказати, чого у нас немає. Якщо хтось був розкуркулений або депортований,
за цими документами потрібно звертатися в архіви Міністерства внутрішніх справ
або регіональні архіви відповідно. Якщо ж людина була репресована
з політичних мотивів, то, як правило, ця інформація буде в нас
або ж ми будемо знати, де можна цю інформацію знайти.
Архіви зі справами репресованих дісталися СБУ фактично у спадок від КДБ
після розпаду СРСР. У майбутньому ж усі архівні документи
періоду з 1919 по 1991  рік мають бути зібрані в єдиному місці -
Архіві національної пам’яті. Усього тут планують зберігати та надавати
у користування охочим 4 млн екземплярів. Утім, наразі роботи над реконструкцією
приміщення для зберігання архіву ще навіть не розпочалися через відсутність державного фінансування.
Тому поки працівники архіву консультують українців, які шукають правдиві відомості
про своїх репресованих родичів. По допомогу вже звернулися понад 1500 людей.
Найбільш запитувана інформація - це з чого почати пошук.
Дуже часто все, що люди знають, це якась дуже маленька інформація,
що передавалася з вуст в уста про те, що дійсно в 30-40-х роках родичі
були репресовані. З чого почати пошук? Дуже часто немає абсолютно ніяких документів.
Власне, наше завдання - допомогти в цьому пошуку і показати, що це легко.
Для того, щоб звернутися, насправді необхідно дуже мінімум інформації.
Це прізвище, ім'я, по-батькові, дата народження, місце народження, обставини репресії.
Цього достатньо, щоб написати звернення.
І відповідно до особливостей, що запитує людина,
ми підказуємо, в які архіви звертатися.
Допомагають у пошуку репресованих родичів і ті, хто вже успішно пройшов цей шлях.
Для цього люди об’єднуються у спільноти в соцмережах.
Олександр Атамась також поділився своєю історією у Фейсбуці,
аби спонукати інших українців не залишати білих плям у минулому родин.
А сам і надалі планує досліджувати своє коріння, в тому числі вивчаючи архівні документи.
Напевно, справа не тільки у відновленні справедливості,
тому що всі, хто вчинив ці злочини, вони вже давно покинули нас.
Справа більше в нашому сьогоденні. У тому, як ми живемо,
що ми думаємо, яких ми поглядів дотримуємося, особливо зараз,
коли у нас сьомий рік іде війна неоголошена. У цьому аспекті важливо.
Важливо розуміти, як було, чому ми такі залякані,
чому ми досі перебуваємо у цій внутрішній еміграції.
Тому що на це були певні причини, і люди боялися.
Люди боялися фізичного знищення, і це передавалося з покоління в покоління.
За підрахунками істориків, жертвами політичних репресій в Україні
в період з 1919 по 1991 рік стали майже 10 млн осіб.
Найбільшим місцем поховання закатованих під час допитів
та розстріляних органами НКВС став Биківнянський ліс під Києвом.
Тут захоронили, за різними даними, від 15 до 100 тисяч репресованих.